how do you protect workers rights in the
gig economy these european companies
think it starts with ownership
[Music]
food delivery services have boomed
during the course of the coronavirus
pandemic
but this success has also been dogged by
continued questions around the labor
models that these companies operate
one response comes in the form of co-op
cycle an open source platform
that helps delivery drivers set up their
own local
worker-owned alternatives to these
delivery apps our members
are local cooperatives who
organize themselves in order to provide
careers locally with a different
idea of how delivery services should be
run
meaning by the career that then the
koreas themselves
in the summer of 2019 korra was founded
in the german capital of berlin as one
of these delivery collectives
my name is anderson i'm part of kova a
worker-owned delivery collector from
berlin
we're trying to have like less as much
hero keys possible which is not always
working fine but
mostly therefore we are organized in a
great plenary which
takes part every two weeks i riding
mostly
and doing dispatching i also onboard new
prider
and i doing marketing stuff co-op cycles
federation
includes over 60 distinct apps that are
operating around europe
the main reason why people come to us is
the the software this kind of technology
is so expensive to develop on
on your own that it makes it
almost impossible to to start off with
your own
application it's like facebook
for restaurants a little every
restaurant can create his own account
and his own page
all the money is transferred over a
coupe cycle all the deliveries
are running over coupe cycle i would say
without coop cycle kora wouldn't access
the apps like cora that use co-op
cycle's open source platform
are localizing the big business of food
delivery while unlikely to be big
competitors in the market
these apps are presenting local
alternative models that could be more
appealing to some restaurants and
customers
my name is tatiana i'm part of the
restaurant neuer republic riga one year
ago we were starting off corona and the
first lockdown
we decided that we need to sell more
food it was clear from the beginning
that we would only
like to deliver by bike and not by car
because it's much more sustainable and
yeah then we found korra
we never thought about like cooperating
with big companies like life for example
and one reason it's very expensive for
the restaurant so if we make food like
we need to give them like 30 percent
which is like super much so that we
can't keep so much money it's like
more work than we get money back we are
a little cheaper and we are much closer
to the restos because we are like
everybody is from here living here
knowing the restaurants i really like it
that they don't have a hierarchy
they're collectively organized and this
is the kind of
structure we would like to support but
we have a lot of
exclusive restaurants that would not
work
on any other platform this has changed a
little bit
due to the covid crisis and the fact
that a lot of restaurant owners
had to use a delivery if they wanted to
stay open and stay alive now that the
restaurants are open
i'm pretty sure a lot of them will drop
uber and drop
delivery and will remain only with us
because of this we do not want to work
with these people who do not match our
values
kind of thing it's not really about the
app but also the app
has like some good points for us it's
like an
open source app and yeah koga is like
super transparent so you see
who's getting how much money who's
paying how much money
our motivation is about showing that
employment
in the business of food delivery can
work people being paid per hour
this can work as well it's not only
about who is
it's how you want tomorrow's society to
be
you